You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio.
Y. C. N. N. P. R. Hello, I'm Jad boom, rod. Hello, I'm Robert Quilt.
This is radio lab, the podcast, which means it's not the broadcast,
not the one hour show, not the one hour. Shows this a little tidbit.
This is a tidbit,
but this is a tidbit with a teasing purpose because we have in the,
in the next few weeks we are going to do the real shows about race.
And there's one about choice. There's one,
however entirely devoted to the subject of sperm and sperm. You think, well,
why would you spend so much time talking about that? Yes, in fact is very sad,
sad, lonely show. Anyhow, we learned a lot of,
I mean if you open up any little basket and ask too many questions,
you learn all kinds of fascinating. So true, particularly with sperm. So, um,
we talked when we were preparing this hour with a woman named Joanna Ellington,
a fertility expert who runs a company with a very short name,
Kinda like spreading itself. M. I. N. G. It's a fertility firm.
And I asked her if you are a healthy male at the very top of your game,
so you got everything you're ever going to have and they're all frisky little
guys ready to go,
what proportion of your gang would be fit and ready to do the deed?
A normal ejaculate from a man is if you have 14 one four 14% or more of the
sperm that are normally shaped, that's very low percent.
86% are abnormally shaped. Yeah.
How do they differ from the normal?
Typically you're going to have problems with the tail and then that makes it so
they can't swim. Right? They swim in a circle, can't swim fast.
Some of them swim in a circle and when they go bang and off you go.
They just go round and round and round and round. Right.
And that doesn't work very well. Of course. Okay. Circles slow. Anything else?
Yeah, as the sperm get ready to be a jack elated,
the tail unwind from around the cell. Okay.
And sometimes it doesn't unwind, right?
It stays wound up or the very tip of the tail stays in kind of an a not,
I guess you could say basically. So you've got a knock on your tail. Yeah,
we've got some stalled out. Some going in circles.
Some going slowly I there I'm horror. Mu Mutant to sperm.
Yeah.
There's one called Globo sperm mia and that is a very large round head.
It's a,
you may be three or four times normal size and instead of having that oval,
it's just quite round looking like a balloon head. Big Fat balloon head. Yeah,
exactly.
You can have sperm that have vacuoles which are basically holes in the DNA.
You can have sperm that have two tails. Yeah. You
know, you don't want anything abnormal double-headed ones. Yes,
absolutely. Triple headed ones.
Um, probably some, this is making me nervous. Anything else?
Some of them are going to be dead and not moving at all. Well that's a problem.
Yeah. In addition to that, there's many,
many micro biochemical things that they have to go through.
So if you were to actually write down everything that could go wrong with sperm
as it meets, it goes to meet the eggs,
it would be hundreds of little enumerations that could go wrong.
But that's why men makes from all the time. They constantly are making it.
They constantly have a fresh supply.
You've got to have something that can go through all the hurdles and all the
barriers and make sure at the end of the day that you have the best healthiest
sperm cell that's participating in making a baby.
The, when you say get that, it's lonely, sad, sad with ads like that.
But member, this is when you're healthiest, when you're healthy.
If I don't get though is like how does it, how does it, well,
this is what we're going to go into the show, but I'll just ask you now,
how does it happen given all of those potential pitfalls and that every sperm is
re outracing the other sperm, it's all the, the, the,
the public image here is that every guy that you put in is in a woody Allen
movie sense competing against his neighbor. Right?
So it's Jerry versus Ted versus Andy versus mark versus Freddy versus Billy.
And they're all rushing to the goal. What if Jerry and Ted and mark and Farrah,
whoever and Billy are all double headed with with them,
they don't make it so it's the odds are not in our favor,
but there is a level of cooperation we discovered while doing this, uh,
that deeply surprising sperm are not always about competing against each other.
And this we learned from Tim Burkhead who's a biologist at the University of
Sheffield. Uh, he told us the story about it was a, a wood mouse,
a w o o not it could mountain or I should know this is a,
this was a wood Woodmass, which actually a gift would mouse.
My colleague Harry Moore, who's a a sperm biologist here in Sheffield. Um,
his cat brought in a wood mouse.
Le Laid it on the dining room floor and he looked at it and thought, gosh,
that's got large testicles.
He dissects and usual reaction to a Katz gift that I've heard in lung.
I'll say, if you're a testicle guy, you're a testicle guy.
You want to take a closer look. Anyway, so he dissects the uh,
he dissects the vows and then carefully removed the sperm inside and then he
looked at the shape of the sperm. This was interesting. All rodents, the,
uh, the sperm has a slightly hooked shaped head,
but in the wood mouse now hook is extreme.
So much so that the hook bends right back and touches the head again.
What Harry notice was that looked as though the hook was a specific adaptation
to grasp the tails of other sperm.
This sperm on its head was a kind of grasping hook,
which suggested that maybe this spring wanted to hold hands.
Some things you put the sperm into our kind of special sperm medium and to his
amazement,
the sperm all joined up together in what he called sperm trains.
Barium T. R. A. I. N. S. Yes. Like in a railway train.
The Tales of other sperm were held by this hook and it's just head to tail,
head to tail. It looks at, it's a bit messy.
It's a bit like spaghetti moving forward. Okay.
The amazing thing is when he measured the speed at which the sperm trains moved,
it was about twice that of isolated sperm. But wait a second,
when if,
if me and 700 others of us or 10 of us get together at the head and,
and swim together, our tales all increasing our speed,
who gets to be the daddy's brain? Then the wood mouse,
some of the sperm undergo what's called the acrosome reaction,
releasing this hook. And when that happens,
those sperm can no longer fertilized,
but they free a vanguard or sperm that then can fertilize and then they give up
for their brethren. Yeah, that's exactly it. Wow.
So then it's not fair to say that in down there at the spring loads every sperm
for himself in a few cases, the springs is there for the other guy. Yeah.
But they're all part of the same ejaculate,
all got roughly the same genetic makeup. All those sperm are related.
So they all have more or less a common interest.
So who do we help each other out? Yeah, I mean this is a, this is different.
However it is. Um, it is at this point, it's just specific to the Woodmass.
So wood mouse sperm seem to have a thing going on amongst us.
And the idea that a sperm would sacrifice itself for a brother's sperm is a very
novel. When you think about how normal normally this is thought of as such a
competitive event. That's right. Well,
any case we hope you'll tune in for that show.
It's coming up in about a month and a half. It's not really a month and a half.
If you're listening to this late in the week,
it's a month and two weeks from now. Okay. That's a month. It's a month.
It's so short. It's really five weeks from now going on four weeks.
And before you know it, it'll be three weeks. Ah. Do you see what I deal with?
Not so can you take them down please?
You can't take me down to pat him down please. Hey Andy Gay.
So visit our website,
Radiolab that or you can find out more about anything on our website and also we
should say a, we should give thanks.
We are funded by the corporation for public broadcasting. Oh wait. Hey, click.
Take him down.
The National Science Foundation and the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
who this month is honoring flash of genius,
the winner of the 2008 feature feature film prize in science and technology at
the Hamptons international film festival.
I'm Jad Abumrad okay. You can put them back up now. Obert Krulwich
we'll see you soon.